car avant de passer à nos autres invités
je voudrais vous faire une interview tir
aux pigeons mais un tir aux pigeons cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors quand qu'est ce que vous appréciez
le plus c'est jean françois copé son
orgue bon tant pis
qu'est ce que vous appréciez chez pierre
gattaz
le fait qu'il me fasse apprécié laurence
parisot finale
crise a précisé
nicolas sarkozy de son absence
il est bon
chez très apprécié chez frédéric
beigbeder lui lui lui le magazine ah
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous appréciez chez manuel
valls
j'apprécie le fait qu'il y ait 12000
régularisation de sans-papiers en plus
en 2013 ça vous plaît ça ouais qu'est ce
que vous appréciez chez enora malagré
c'est une interview en anglais
et dernière question qu'est ce que vous
appréciez chez vous mes amis j'ai
beaucoup d'amis plus que certains le
pensent
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus